foreign
fly from America to Europe this year
you'll have noticed that there's a whole
bunch of airlines that seem to suddenly
be offering very cheap fares Airlines
like Norse French bee and play have all
been trying to capture a wave of
post-pandemic Revenge spending
transatlantic Travelers by trying to
lower their ticket prices as much as
possible and their tactics Go Far Far
further than just charging for the seat
and separating out added extras it's
more about getting every part of your
business at the lowest possible costs
but major Legacy airlines are competing
hard on pricing so much so that
sometimes they even undercut the
low-cost carriers and now with winter
around the corner and demand set to fall
there's a huge question over the
long-term viability of low-cost
transatlantic flight so are these
Airlines and their airfares set to
disappear as quickly as they arrived
let's find out
okay so first I want to know how these
low-cost airlines are getting their
ticket prices down and so to do that
I've come to visit North Atlantic the
company was formed in Norway after the
pandemic and has 15 of these Boeing 787
Dreamliners 10 of which it currently
operates from America to Europe now part
of what helps North gets its prices down
is by doing something called unbundling
ancillaries which in plain English is
basically charging separately for
everything other than the seat flying
its most basic fare North will charge
you to check in a bag or to bring a
carry-on or to choose which seat you
want to sit in meals will cost extra as
will priority boarding and check-in
Norse makes around 87 per passenger on
ancillaries on every flight around a
fifth of all passenger revenue and has
aims to become the highest ancillary
Revenue per passenger airline globally
but any Airline including the big Legacy
carriers can and often do on bundle
their ticket prices so much so that
revenue from ancillaries are across the
aviation industry has doubled since 2013
to Total over a hundred billion dollars
so to really get prices down especially
as a startup you need to go even further
and for Norse that started with getting
these aircraft for cheap it was really
an acid plainishly where we got the
assets at historic low prices are in
very flexible terms that
yo Bjorn Tor Larson who told me that
norse's streamlined operations in an
attempt to minimize costs we fly Long
Haul only if I run the aircraft pipe to
Dreamliner only so all our crew are
trained on only one type of aircraft we
only do one type of Maintenance the
company also operates some of its
flights from cheaper airports like
flying out of Gatwick instead of
Heathrow though they do have a slot at
New York's JFK and instead of flying out
of and back to a fixed Hub norces planes
fly onward from each destination you
don't have a lot of costs that is
associated with the Hub and spoke
operation where you are into a much much
more complex operation straight away now
all of these factors have helped Norse
get pricing down and Achieve
profitability for the first time this
year but here's the thing
Norse isn't actually always that much
cheaper than major legacy US carriers
see airline prices vary wildly depending
on how far in advance you book how long
your stay is and whether you plan on
flying one way or return but if you
compare the prices for this flight
between Norse Delta and United North
averaged around 615 and United was 660.
now if you include the fact that Delta
and United's price includes a carry-on
bag and a meal which would cost you
upwards of fifty dollars on Norse then
that price Gap soon starts to shrink so
how are these Legacy carriers able to
get their prices down because of the
scale and the amount of capacity they
have and that brings their unit cost
down that's John Grant chief analyst at
Aviation data firm oag if a legacy
airliner's got 1500 Economy seats spread
across seven flights during the day then
they're able to match that another
reason is that economy seats are only
make up a small fraction of Legacy
Airlines cabins the rest being far more
profitable premium economy business and
first class seats and that kind of
explains why when I search for tickets
around Labor Day Norse was more
expensive than some major US Rivals
sometimes our browsers are going up a
little bit and that is basically because
of the cabin is being filled so
the Last Passenger is actually paying
quite a bit more than the first
passenger now recently demand has been
so strong that there's been enough
flyers for both low-cost carriers and
Legacy carriers to be able to profit the
relative strength of the US dollar has
encouraged a lot of your North American
visitors and we've been blessed with
just enough capacity but as the summer
season draws to a close International
demand is set to drop and that's got
some wondering whether these low-cost
long-haul carriers will be able to
survive the winter is it sustainable
long term
no
after all other airlines have in the
past tried and failed to make low-cost
transatlantic flight commercially
sustainable
for years Norwegian air used to operate
a budget-friendly route between Europe
and America but the company faced a
whole bunch of headwinds from operating
Boeing planes that were grounded during
the max crisis to trying to juggle a
wide array of routes they heard embarked
on rapid growth they had a short haul
Network and a long-haul Network they
spread themselves too thinly too quickly
during the pandemic the company filed
for bankruptcy protection restructured
reduced its Fleet from 156 aircraft to
51 and crucially discontinued long-haul
operations what's not certainly is how
sustainable this is long term what are
your what are your views you're
absolutely right it's yet to be proven
and it has not a great history but
here's the thing many of norse's planes
are actually old Norwegian planes so is
the company set to suffer the same fate
I don't totally agree that we are born
out of the ashes because we are a brand
new Airline we have no Hub and spoke
operations we don't own you know short
all operations trying to put everything
together it's it's very different you
still have winter coming and you've said
yourself you know demand fluctuates are
you worried about some of the winter
months I'm always worried that's my job
you know I'm born and we really have to
be very careful it's easy to burn a lot
of money if you get things wrong so how
can these low-cost carriers survive
winter well one option is to chase the
warmer weather and adjust your roots a
Norse plan on doing just that opening up
winter routes to Barbados Jamaica and
even adding a new route to Bangkok in
Asia but shifting key routes when you
don't have many planes can create
another headache dipping in and dipping
out of markets is a
relatively high risk strategy because
your brand awareness and your presence
is not as large as the other carriers
who are there year round so another
tactic is to try and carry more cargo
providing there's more cargo to be
carried we are definitely seeing a
better cargo Market typically during the
winter but you you don't know and so you
can't take that for granted and if those
fail well hunker down for the cold
months and conduct your scheduled
maintenance while your Fleet is out of
use Norse told me that they'd try all of
these tactics but the aviation industry
can be pretty Cutthroat and while
low-cost carriers brace for the winter
Legacy carriers will capture every
Advantage if the market becomes a little
bit tougher those Legacy carriers are
not going to say the market Shores
they're going to compete for every seat
with you and that that's a challenge
foreign